but Nestle's in Detroit Michigan hi
Vanessa how are you this is actually
Adrienne hey Vanessa we're married and
we called in to get some advice on how
we should pursue our paths right now
cool how can I help right now we have a
hundred and twenty three thousand gross
annually but I take home is about fifty
five hundred a month and we have a
hundred and eighty three thousand in
student loans about ten thousand and
credit cards our rent is currently 675
in the apartment we were recently
married this year and we graduated this
year and so it's possibly going to be
point up next month
because we got it during the good time
when everything was low dollar all your
it was the doctor or lawyer oh no I'm a
nurse and she's a social worker so
harder than ain't done three thousand
did I hear that right
yeah hold on a little bit longer than we
were supposed to be holy what a mess
yeah yeah so what is your all's income
doing 123 sounds low well yeah we just
started well I just started and she just
got a raise with because she got her
master's and I just graduated so that's
where income is right now who just
graduated this note already
we both graduated she got her master's
and I just finished by my RN degree okay
so you're in the nurse Social Work oh
yeah right now number one your take-home
pay is wrong or your gross is wrong or
you got a bunch of crap coming out of
your check that doesn't need to be yeah
we have we're still doing our 401 K
you're broke you don't need to be doing
a 401 K you're a hundred and eighty
three thousand dollars our student loan
debt you don't need to be doing anything
that's the other question that we kind
of had because we're and a student loan
repayment programs and it drops off in
ten years so we're trying to we're in
the process of trying to look for a
house because I rent will be going up
when we renew in August no way
possibly go up to $800 no way and trying
to see if we better to find a hole no in
that same payment range no no no no no
no you are broke you do not need to buy
a house with a hundred eighty-three
thousand dollars in student loan debt
you get the cheapest possible wrench you
can you need to get your take home pay
correct it and start bringing a whole
lot more of at home stopping all
investing you need to stop everything
and you need to keep living like you
were called broke college students
because you aren't broke and list your
debts smallest to largest pay minimum
payments on everything but the little
one an attack this I'm not waiting 10
years to get out of that well I think we
might end up waiting that long why that
long why but it just feels like that
with the way our income is versus how
much we have okay let's do a little math
alright let's still oh man what did you
guys write the year before you graduated
your students well the year before I
graduated my income was about twenty
thousand yeah it was was still losers
fifty okay so your income has virtually
doubled in one year okay if you were to
keep your lifestyle super low like a
fifty thousand dollar lifestyle and you
make a hundred and twenty three that's
seventy thousand dollars not counting
taxes okay 123 minus fifty if you lived
on 50 which is doable for a young couple
getting started as a matter of fact the
average household income in America is
only 59 so I know it's doable okay so
let's say you lived on 50 and you put
twenty in taxes and you put fifty
thousand dollars a year on this two
hundred thousand divided by 50 is what
four years everything you're telling me
okay I'm sorry you have a hundred eighty
three thousand dollars in student loan
debt plus all the other crap right so if
you throw 50 thousand dollars a year at
your debt for four years that's two
hundred thousand dollars isn't it yeah
50 times four
okay you're debt-free now here's what's
going to happen you're going to do it in
three years because your income that
you're giving me right here is your
starter income and as a nurse you have a
wonderful field career field that you
are entering you have unbelievable
income earning opportunities okay and
your income is going to go up very
quickly
and even if it doesn't go up at the
particular job you're at it can go up
just by working the ER you got all kinds
of places you can pick up extra jobs as
a nurse and make serious Bank if our
goal is now because I want you to get a
house I just don't want you to get a
house while you're broke because it'll
kill you okay and so I want you to get
this mess cleaned up because if you move
in a house with all this debt you have
to buy an extra bedroom just for Sallie
Mae I mean you this is this is a lot of
weight and I certainly don't want to
walk around with it for ten years so my
game plan for you guys would be that you
get very focused and very intense you
stop all investing temporarily you stop
all saving temporarily you get on a
beans and rice rice and beans no life
budget like you were a college student
making fifty grand and you throw every
squeeze every dollar out of each
paycheck that you can find and you throw
it at your smallest debt first pay that
off your next smallest debt and pay that
off you don't borrow anymore you get out
the credit cards and cut them up you get
in a tack mode like it was like you were
in the ER trying to save somebody's life
clear right I mean you got to get after
it that's what you got to do here
because otherwise you're gonna you're
gonna waste your life away for a decade
you won't give a decade to this stuff no
way thinking about how much would be
forgiven so I thought that was a good
idea no no because what you're going to
lose seven years of your life that's
what you're gonna lose yeah and you just
don't it's not worth it you the
beautiful thing about your particular
career track is you have the ability
make a lot of money as a nurse as an RN
I mean you you really there's you you're
always gonna get find employment and you
can always get extra employment out
there so did you say you guys just got
mer
- yeah cool well congratulations
have you heard me talk about you sound
like you're kind of new to all this
have you heard me talk about our class
Financial Peace University well no we've
actually been through the class and
we're kind of redoing it right now yeah
you need to because you didn't get it
cuz you just call me up and ask me to
buy a house with 183 thousand dollars in
debt so that means you didn't get the
class because the student loan repayment
forgiveness wasn't addressed in the
class so we're going the snowball but we
didn't know about since its forgiven
should we be making our minimum payments
and allow it to be forgiven and just
leave that income if it wasn't if it
wasn't a decade of your life that you
were a slave you know if it was three
years we talked about it but it's a
decade and if you had almost no income
upside potential and you got tremendous
income upside potential so yeah go back
through the class then get a reset get
refocused get re-energized reset your
goals jump on get every dollars budgets
going you need to get over and stop your
401k you need to do that already and you
didn't do it and you need to stop all
savings temporarily and you make sure no
other trash is coming out of your check
and they're not over withholding on you
so that you get big refunds you don't
want a big refund that's just you give
them the government too much money and
we're going to just dial everything and
dial everything in dial everything in
row squeeze every dime out of your life
and we're clear this debt off the table
fast then you save up your emergency
fund and then you go buy you a house but
that's the smart way to do it this is
the price you're paying for having been
unbelievably sloppy in your study
process and in what you were willing to
pay for your education because you guys
have overpaid for your education
tremendously and you got a mess on your
hands as a result so but you clean it up
you can clean it up you got a good
future but don't don't just fall into
slavery mentality I'm gonna be in there
for a decade please don't do that please
please please don't do that